[Musique]
le report
une grande cour au milieu en lieu et
place du donjon habituel c'est la
première chose qui saisit tout visiteur
avec son style singulier presque
dépouiller le château de druides et
bellefontaine un trick guide depuis dix
ans roland gros le constate à chaque
visite les gens repartent toujours très
satisfait le bien souvent aidé ben
sedrine non c'est pas une semaine qui
parle donc il ya une histoire ancienne
demeure des comtes de nevers et
d'auxerre le château est longtemps resté
délaissé il faudra attendre des années
60 et l'action de l'un des habitantes
l'instituteur du village pour qu'ils
sortent de l'oubli
le château quand monsieur nemo qui est
instituteur au village est arrivé en
iran 58
tout était en ruines il y avait des
premiers au mieux dacourt et tout de
suite il a eu envie de faire vivre le
château et dans les années 60 70
il ya eu pendant dix ans des sons et
lumières qui ont été très importants un
héritage que félix moureaux et
l'association des amis du château
tentent de perpétuer
depuis 2003 on fait du théâtre ça fait
six ans qu'on fait du théâtre tous les
ans besoin de théâtre dans la cour du
château oui pour faire quand même vivre
le château
théâtre mais aussi visites guidées aux
boutiques toutes ces animations permis
tour à tour aux différents propriétaires
de restaurer le château
aujourd'hui le site se visitent
entièrement il abrite une chapelle qui
elle aussi est loin d'avoir livré tous
ses secrets
[Musique]
début de souterrains au site pour
sépultures sont la grille le trou de
plusieurs mètres restent à ce jour
toujours inexpliqué c'est là justement
tout le charme du château de druides et
belfort
la visite se termine par la tour porsche
et la montée de ses 89 marche pour
arriver au sommet c'est l'apothéose on
quand un auteur de vingt mètres
on voit 20 km environ les gens forment
toujours très content de finir et c'est
surtout parole bottom actuellement en
travaux le château de druides et
bellefontaine n'en finit plus de se
refaire une beauté atypique inclassable
il attire chaque année plus de 4000
visiteurs